welcome to the man of recaps this is
obi-wan kenobi season one ten years
after the fall of the republic and the
rise of the empire in revenge of the
sith obi-wan kenobi is hiding out on
tatooine he has a sad lonely life here
living in a cave with his only hobby
being stalking the 10 year old boy a
young luke skywalker meanwhile across
the galaxy on the beautiful paradise
planet of alderaan luke's sister leia is
living as a princess but today she meets
a gang of kidnappers and it's a
comically bad chase scene as these grown
grown-ass adults can't catch this little
kid eventually they do though so her
adopted parents reach out to obi-wan
help us obi-wan kenobi you're our only
hope but obi-wan has to stay hidden
because the inquisitors are hunting down
all remaining jedi we get to know this
one who they call third sister and her
boss the high inquisitor just really
doesn't like her and so to avoid being
identified as a jedi obi-wan goes
incognito wearing exactly what jedi wear
soleil has been taken to this crime
planet where obi-wan hears tell of
another jedi oh snap it's kuma nanjani
it quickly becomes apparent he's not a
real jedi he's just faking it but he
does know where leia is probably being
held so obi-wan goes full walter white
as he's gotta break into a star wars
meth lab but wait that's not leia it's a
trap yeah third sister hired these guys
specifically to lure obi-wan out of
hiding anyway the trap fails and obi-wan
rescues leia and these two have a cute
relationship she's real precocious and
makes fun of him for being old but third
sister's hunting him down running around
the rooftops with some epic parkour but
soon her boss shows up and she's like
hey i found obi-wan but he's mad at her
for some reason even though hunting jedi
is their job obi-wan's new friend is
gonna help them escape but third sister
tracks him down and to lure him out of
hiding she drops a truth bomb on him
anakin skywalker is still alive he is
darth vader oh mind blown you mean to
tell me that the super powerful dark
side force user that appeared
mysteriously out of nowhere right after
anakin turned to the dark side and i
left him there very much alive are the
same guy just then her boss shows up
like you're in big trouble for almost
catching a jedi and so she's gotta kill
him and obi-wan escapes obi-wan and leia
hitch a ride from this farmer but he
also picks up some stormtroopers they're
like hey we're hunting for a jedi
middle-aged guy big beard brown robes
traveling with a young girl have you
seen anything like that eventually
though they check his id so he's gotta
fight him off with a blaster fight oh so
uncivilized and he just easily took out
six stormtroopers but when three more
reinforcements show up well that's too
many we'd better surrender but what's
this their commanding officer turns on
them oh yeah she's undercover she really
is an imperial officer but she realized
the empire's evil so now she's joined
the resistance working like an
underground railroad but now darth vader
himself gets word obi-wan's been found
and decides to cut his bath time short
to go catch him tiller kenobi out he
starts killing civilians so it's like
you guys get out of here it's me he
wants obi-wan and anakin come face to
face we meet again at last and so it's a
lightsaber battle
obi wan's out of practice though vader
easily beats him and he lights a fire
yeah man see how you like it but obi's
new friend causes a distraction by
lighting even more of a fire and somehow
gets him to safety but that means she
abandoned her one job of protecting leia
who's now picked up by third sister so
obi-wan meets her resistance friends and
they hatch plan to rescue leia from the
sith inquisitor base which is really
cool like in the water tower her cover's
still intact so she opens a hatch for
obi-wan to swim in once inside he grabs
a stormtrooper for the classic
stormtrooper armor disguise except he
doesn't actually still dressed just like
a jedi intruder so he rescues leia once
again but during the escape a laser hits
the window yeah you shouldn't shoot
lasers in an underwater base obi-wan
boom floods it all now to sneak out of
there obi-wan finally puts on the bare
minimum disguise but they're immediately
caught but now what's this air support
yeah they're rebel friends here to cover
them uh uber for obi-wan darth vader's
real mad they let obi-wan escape but
third sister's like yo i let him escape
on purpose i put a tracker on his ship
and it's like oh you know that's a
really good idea actually i think i'll
do that in a new hope so they make it
back to their hideout but the empire's
on the way oh blowing down the door but
they take a quick break for third sister
and obi-wan to have a little chat where
he realizes her backstory she was one of
the younglings jedi in training that
anakin killed when he turned to the dark
side she wants revenge on anakin for
killing her friends but i mean she's
still darkseid so they have a big
shootout pew pew pew obi-wan's new
girlfriend has to sacrifice herself but
now it's like look you guys get out of
here it's me he wants so obi-wan turns
himself in but he's like look third
sister this is your chance let's slar
vader into a trap so when vader gets
down there she's like yeah kenobi's in
the back and by the time he gets over
there oh their ship's escaping but wow
vader grabs it okay cool he's not
messing around except obi-wan was one
step ahead that was a decoy ship and so
they get away and instead of attacking
him 10 seconds earlier while he was
distracted wrangling a ship third sister
decides to make her move now and goes
for the slowest most telegraph overhand
attack which is obviously caught by the
way she also has a super cool spinny
lightsaber which turns out to also be
useless but vader's in the mood for a
fight so he gives her half a lightsaber
and toys with her for a bit before
revealing he's the best and so for the
second time in her life darth vader
stabs her and leaves her to die and to
make things worse her douchebag boss
made a full recovery so yeah bad day for
her but earlier bail organa called
obi-wan to check in on the rescue of
leia and for being the biggest secret in
the galaxy he speaks pretty explicitly
about vader's son on tatooine so third
sister instantly teleports across the
galaxy to tatooine to find him the
rebels meanwhile have not thought this
escaped through there's still an
imperial star destroyer right there in
orbit but obi-wan kenobi's got a plan to
save him you guys get out of here it's
me he wants so he lures vader down for
their final rematch i will do what i
must and oh he does his iconic pose so
it's finally time yeah yeah a real epic
lightsaber battle obi-wan invader
but calm down a bit don't enjoy it too
much let's intercut it with scenes on
tatooine of uncle owen and aunt peru uh
defending luke and their farm it's like
wait a sec third sister what do you want
with luke in the first place and she
hasn't really thought the plan through i
guess she's gonna kill luke then tell
vader it was his son to make him then
mad after the fact but back to the fight
vader's done messing around causes an
earthquake and buries obi-wan alive but
obi-wan's done messing around too he
finds the strength within him shows that
he's still got it boom force throwing
rocks at this guy yeah so many rocks and
now he attacks vader's weak spot to the
suit you know that's keeping him alive
and why big slice on the helmet and now
we get to see a half-hating christensen
face it's like anakin bro i'm so sorry i
failed you but anakin's full darth vader
it's like nah i killed anakin skywalker
and obi-wan's like well from a certain
point of view but it's a great intense
moment as these two are reunited face to
face and obi-wan's like well see you
later darth and leaves him there again
meanwhile third sister got luke but
seeing him there reminds her of herself
and she's like oh if i kill him i'm just
as bad as anakin was so she doesn't kill
him brings him home safe obi-wan also
now instantly teleported across the
galaxy to tatooine she's like what do i
do now it's like duh you have a
redemption arc silly and so the day is
saved princess leia is reunited with her
family got her new best friend uncle
obi-wan i'll call on you later if i ever
need help and you're my only hope then
back home obi-wan decides to stop
stalking luke and actually introduce
himself and obi-wan kenobi's starting to
figure out the whole incognito thing
what's up call me ben kenobi but we're
not done yet it's cameo time as darth
vader face times with his boss emperor
palpatine it's like hey man obi-wan
totally kicked your butt like you don't
have to come into the death star today
take a few days to recoup and then it's
time for a forced ghost of liam neeson
obi-wan's old master qui-gon jinn it's
like wait master you're a ghost you're
telling me we could have hung out all
these last 10 years and he's like
obi-wan i was always there you just
weren't ready to see me and that's where
obi-wan kenobi season one comes to an
end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and news
[Music]